[Musik]
irgendwann hat er mir dann gesagt ja er
hat sich jetzt in mich verliebt aber
Boris haben ausgeprägt psychopathische
Eigenschaften exzellenten manipulations
Fähigkeiten dann hat er angefangen mich
mit in Bordelle zu nehmen damit kann man
halt gut Geld verdienen ich war ja 17
ich war ja noch minderjährig ich habe
einfach dann einen Freier nach dem
anderen bedient bis es 6 Uhr war ich
hatte jeden Tag Schmerzen und musste
dann trotzdem am nächsten Morgen wieder
antreten wir beherrschen dieses Spiel
mit Zuckerbrot und Peitsche der hat mir
mit seinen Schuhen in die Rippen
getreten steh auf du scheiß Tier bis
dato war er aber der einzige Mensch der
für mich da war der immer lieb zu mir
war ich habe mich auch total geschämt
dass sich das überhaupt gemacht hat dass
ich das angefangen habe ich war ihm
danach auch noch hörig ich habe ihn auch
lange Zeit danach noch geliebt
[Musik]
Sandra norak ist 16 Jahre alt als ich
das erste Mal verliebt der Mann den sie
über das Internet kennengelernt hat ist
doppelt so alt wie sie in privaten Chats
vertraut sie ihm die intimsten Dinge an
ihre Magersucht die Probleme mit ihrer
psychisch kranken Mutter er hört dir zu
steht dir mit Einsicht und Verständnis
immer zur Seite er hat mich gepackt eben
durch diese emotionalen Sachen und hat
da genau gewusst welche Knöpfe er
drücken muss er hat so auf den
Beschützer gemacht irgendwann hat er mir
dann gesagt ja er hat sich jetzt in mich
verliebt und er würde mich gerne real
Kennenlernen das paar trifft sich von da
an regelmäßig war Sandra norak zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht Arndt hinter der
vermeintlich großen Liebe steckt in
Wahrheit ein sogenannter Loverboy ein
Zuhälter der die Verliebtheit seiner
Frauen Skrupel muss ausgenutzt dann
hatte halt irgendwann angefangen mich
mit in Bordelle zu nehmen und dann ging
es eben kurz danach los mit dieser
Schulden Marshall wer wo er dann zu mir
gesagt hat ja aber damit kann man halt
gut Geld verdienen und das war so dass
ich dort eingearbeitet wurde von einer
Frau die schon für ihn als Prostituierte
gearbeitet hatte
das Leben der jungen Frau beginnt sich
in einen Albtraum zu verwandeln noch
hofft sie auf die Liebe ihres Freundes
doch nach und nach wird immer deutlicher
dass sie in eine ausweglose liebes Falle
getappt ist die perfide Masche der
Loverboys die Sicherheitsbehörden sie in
eine steigende Gefahr in dieser Pandemie
hat der Nutzen dieser digitalen Medien
natürlich Menschen enorm zugenommen
viele dieser sozialen Kontakte spielen
sich zur Zeit fast ausschließlich
digital ab und deren Logos früher sonst
ganz klasse schon Diskotheken gewartet
haben um Frauen anzusprechen sind sie
natürlich wohl auch viel mehr digital
auf der Suche und
diese ganze digital Nutzen der ist so
viel mehr geworden das natürlich auch
dort die Anbahnung sehr viel mehr steigt
[Musik]
offiziell wurden 2019 durch Loverboy 81
Frauen Opfer von sexueller Ausbeutung
doch die Behörden gehen von einer
weitaus höheren Dunkelziffer aus denn
viele Opfer trauen sich nicht die Täter
bei der Polizei anzuzeigen aus Scham und
Angst die Frauen sind sehr stark
psychisch aufhängeschiene neben den
vermeintlichen Alternativen
die heute 39-Jährige Katharina wurde
Opfer eines Loverboy auch ihr Schicksal
typisch sie wächst in Süddeutschland auf
der Vater ist Rechtsanwalt die Mutter
Erzieherin mit 14 Jahren verliebt sie
sich in ihrem 50-jährigen Reitlehrer wir
nennen ihn Heinz von ihm bekommt sie die
Zuneigung und Anerkennung die sie in
ihrem Elternhaus oft vermisst mit 17
Jahren bricht sie den Kontakt zu ihrer
Familie ab diese ruft die Polizei zeigt
Heinz an doch nichts geschieht Katharina
bleibt bei ihm ein fataler Fehler er
schickt sie auf den Strich
Katharina möchte nicht erkannt werden
wir haben ihre Stimme verfremdet ich war
damals nur sprachlos ich dachte immer
das kann nicht wahr sein das will er
nicht ernsthaft von mir das verlangt er
nicht aber ich wusste nicht wohin ich
war mit allen Vor stritten
für mich bestand überhaupt nicht die
Möglichkeit gar nicht nach Hause zu
gehen ich hatte nur ihn
es gab keinen anderen Weg weil es nicht
so einfach war ich war ja 17 ich war ja
noch minderjährig und eine Minderjährige
unterzubringen ist auch nicht so einfach
wir sind dann nach Mannheim gefahren
und dort wurde ich in einem Laufhaus
untergebracht was für mich auch
schrecklich war weil die Mädchen alle
russisch Sprachen
trotz des Ekels vor den fremden Männern
will Katharina bei Heinz bleiben sie
will ihn nicht aufgeben und träumt von
einer glücklichen Zukunft mit ihm auf
dem gemeinsamen Reiterhof ich musste
mich dann arbeitstauglich machen und
wurde in die Küche gerufen wo die
Betreiberin mich dann begutachtet hat
und der Wirtschaft aber dabei
das war wie fleischbeschauung ob die
Ware taugt und um 18 Uhr ging es dort
los von 18 Uhr bis 6 Uhr
und dann mussten wir uns alle auf die
Barhocker vor unseren Zimmern setzen und
dann kam die Freya
ich habe einfach dann einen Freier nach
dem anderen bedient bis es 6 Uhr war und
dann wurde abgesperrt in den ersten
beiden Monaten habe ich jeweils 50000
Mark verdient
auch nach einem Jahr im Bordell glaubt
Katharina immer noch dem Versprechen von
Heinz dass sie bald aufhören können
wieder eine Lüge mehr als elf Jahre wird
die junge Frau als Prostituierte für ihn
arbeiten
die Psychologin dr Nakhla seimi
Untersuch das Verhalten von Straftätern
sie weiß warum lavaboys auf junge Frauen
so überzeugend wirken häufig ist es
ebenso das ausgeprägt sympathische
Eigenschaften weil diesen lavaboys
vorhanden sind sind sehr nazistisch sie
haben diesen oberflächlichen charme sie
haben diese exzellenten manipulations
Fähigkeiten sie beherrschen dieses Spiel
mit Zuckerbrot und Peitsche ich war
Heinz absolut hörig er hat mir dann auch
immer wieder Sachen gekauft womit er
mich dann quasi bei Laune halten konnte
ein tolles Pferd oder ein Traktor und er
hat mir schon von dem Hof erzählt von
unserem Reitstall und so habe ich
gedacht okay das hältst du noch aus so
lange kann es ja nicht mehr dauern
auch Sandra norak verkauft ihren Körper
an fremde Männer alles aus Liebe zu
ihrem Loverboy 6 Jahre lang geht sie für
ihn anschaffen mit 19 arbeitet sie in
einem sogenannten Flatrate Bordell dort
können sich die freie an so vielen
Frauen bedienen wie Sie möchten
ich hatte da bis 20 Uhr freier aber das
waren auch jeden Tag fast wirklich 20
und das war einfach so ein Überladen da
konnte man auch nicht nein sagen zu den
Gästen also ich habe zu den Kästen also
zu den freien ja also ich hatte jeden
Tag Schmerzen und musste dann trotzdem
am nächsten Morgen wieder antreten und
ich weiß nicht dass dass das macht den
Menschen einfach kaputt also das hat
mich definitiv kaputt gemacht und er
wusste das auch Sandra norak
Selbstwertgefühl zerbricht mit jedem
freier immer mehr sie schämt sich meine
die Öffentlichkeit und zieht sich immer
mehr zurück
Aufdruck Ihres Zuhälters bricht Sandra
die Schule ab kurz vor ihrem Abitur
dann kann man auch in so einer Spirale
rein wo diese Leute da man ja auch
vermitteln also auch diese im Bordell ja
Design die Familie die Freunde und sowas
das sind ja so die einzigen Menschen die
man noch hat um seiner Kontrolle
maximalen Ausdruck zu verleihen
sich die Anfang 20 jährige einen Drachen
auf den Rücken tätowieren lassen dieses
Symbol trägt sie bis heute. Ungefähr so
groß
und dazu noch ein keltisches Kreuz und
Totenkopf wenn man sich das Zeitung
genauer anschaut und sitzt nicht
entschlüsselt ja dann kann man halt
sehen dieses Gebiet ja gehört mir also
letztlich ich gehöre ihm auch Katharina
muss ich Aufdruck Ihres lavaboys
körperlich verändern
ich hatte Körbchengröße B also völlig
normal und Heinz meinte wenn ich mir
Riesendinger hinmachen lasse würde ich
wieder viel Geld verdienen und dann
würden wir unseren Traum schneller
erreichen
es geht nicht um diese junge Frau
konkret persönlich als Mensch sondern
sie ist einfach ein Objekt dass man
wirtschaftlich ausbeuten kann was geht
um massivo Unehrlichkeit also zu einem
durchgehen das Konzept des der Art der
Kommunikation und das Beziehungsaufbau
es geht um Reue losigkeit mangelnde
Schuldgefühle absolute
Rücksichtslosigkeit um eigenen Vorteil
zu maximieren
[Musik]
Heinz hat direkt angefangen mich zu
beschimpfen und er hat mir mit seinen
Schuhen in die Rippen getreten und hat
immer wieder gesagt steh auf du scheiß
Tier ist und Anspruchsdenken da wenn
dieses Geld bezahlt wurde dann darf ich
mit diesen Menschen auch machen was
ausgemacht war ihr elender man aussah
und schlimmer Mann verprügelt war desto
begehrter war man bei den Freiern ist
schlimmer ich aussah dass du besser habe
ich verdient ich selber würde schätzen
dass ich ungefähr zwei Millionen Euro
eingebracht habe ich habe mich echt
gesellschaftshunde würdig gefühlt mehr
weil ich mir gedacht habe Aagaard wer
will mit einer wie mir noch was zu tun
haben Selbstmord ist immer präsent ich
stehe früh auf und er ist da in meinem
Kopf
solange er lebt befürchte ich dass er
immer da ist 2010 wollte ich dann meinem
Leben ein Ende setzen
[Musik]